rmx logic data science is a program
focused on data science for biomedical
data
as seen in application to project source
from current topics
in biomedical research in this program
we will focus on methods of data
analysis
and data wrangling essential skills for
bioinformaticians
as well as those interested in other
types of non-biology related research
using data analysis we will take a
variety of research examples and learn
about the logic behind each type of
omics data
used to study cancer tissue biology and
the microbiome
we will speak about data processing a
procedure
to generate a data set or a matrix of
continuous and categorical data
from a biological sample that can be
then visualized
and analyzed in a statistical way to do
so
you will be able to run complex
bioinformatics pipelines
on high performance computing and
cloud-based servers
without slowing down your own computer
and develop
a logical understanding of many methods
involved
in the data preparation steps these are
commonly used
to study dna variation gene expression
protein abundance and composition
properties of microbial communities
these are all very different types of
data that we will learn to explore
and mine for patterns we will learn to
plot histograms
scatter plots and bar plots to find
relationships between data
and explore ways to categorize millions
of data points per sample
then we will use these visual
representations to spot technical noise
that is important to eliminate using
various normalization techniques
and data transformation steps in
practical coding assignments
we will also help you understand the r
and python code
elements that will be a part of any data
science project you end up working on
in your future these exercises are
designed
to explain the code and help you adapt
it to a project of your own
with clean and efficient code practices
we will also have a chance to see how
data could be mined for patterns
and machine learning is used to group
data objects by feature similarity
and models are trained for predictive
analysis
these help simplify data for
visualization
that can then be used for spotting
relationships and patterns
in complex data sets in week one
we will focus on our mix data types
challenges associated with big data
and give you an overview of different
methods to handle and prepare data for
in-depth analysis in week two of the
program
we will focus on multivariate analysis
methods
and examples using machine learning and
artificial intelligence
we welcome you to join the armix logic
data science program
it is a training experience on data
science approaches for biomedical data
as seen in application to project source
from current topics
in biomedical research